Bäume sind Lebewesen und sie leben in
einer geheimnisvollen Welt sie reden
miteinander sie helfen sich gegenseitig
und sie erziehen auch ihre Kinder hier
in diesem Wald dem hümmeler Wald der
4000 Jahre alt ist in einem Buchenwald
sind sie Förster Peter Wohlleben wir
sind sie eigentlich darauf gekommen als
Förster der ja vor allen Dingen hegt und
pflegt wie man so schön sagt nun
plötzlich das Leben der Bäume zu
entdecken also ursprünglich wollte ich
als kleines Kind Naturschützer werden
und habe dann mehr oder weniger zufällig
Forstwirtschaft studiert weil ich dachte
na ja Wald und Natur das ist ja
eigentlich fast dasselbe und habe dann
angefangen konventionell zu wirtschaften
das ist nämlich das was man beigebracht
bekommt nämlich in Plantagen das heißt
also relativ hart mit karlschlägen auch
mit gifteinsetzen und ich habe mich dann
relativ rasch gefragt ist ist das was du
wolltest das ist doch was ganz anderes
und habe mich dann eben anders
orientiert an betrieben die
ökologischwitschaften da gibt es nicht
allzu viele in Deutschland aber es gibt
welche und habe dann eben bei diesem
sanfteren Umgang mit dem Wald auch neue
Dinge entdeckt also z.B eben dass Bäume
ganz soziale Wesen sind ne wir denken ja
bei Bäumen immer sofort an Sauerstoff an
Holz an Wasser also an ganz viele
Dienstleistung für den Menschen und ich
sage immer wer denkt da eigentlich daran
wenn er ein Elefanten sieht so ein Baum
ist für mich praktisch ein Elefant und
das ist das was ich im Bewusstsein gerne
ändern würde dass man die dies es Wesen
für sich selbst schätzen lernt und nicht
für die Dinge die es uns Menschen
liefert man muss genau hingucken das
wollen wir jetzt mal machen in den
nächsten Minuten z.B bei diesem Baum das
ist ja auch eine Art von Elefant und
wenn wir hier stehen und diese enorme
Wurzeln sehen dann sind die ja nicht um
uns schönes Grün zu präsentieren sonder
die haben ja einen Zweck da steckt ja
was dahinter was ist bei diesen Wurzeln
so besonders warum hat er so starke
Wurzeln ausgebildet also Wurzeln kennen
wir als halteorgan oder zum Wasser und
Nährstoffe ansaugen so das ist das was
wir aus dem Biologieunterricht kennen
aber was dieser Mutterbaum um einen
solchen handelt sich nämlich jetzt hier
macht der stillt gerade seine kleinen
Kinder diese kleinen buchen hier die
übrigens schon älter als 10 Jahre sind
die wachsen ganz langsam die sollen
langsam wachsen also baumjugend hat Zeit
z 300 Jahre bevor sie ins vielleicht in
die Schule und irgendwann ins
Erwachsenen Leben St dürfen ganz ganz
langsam und damit sie auf dieser Zeit
einigermaßen durchs Leben kommen damit
sie genug Energie haben deswegen werden
sie über wurzelverwachsung von diesem
alten Baum ja regelrecht gestillt also
mit Zuckerlösung versorgt jetzt hat man
die Verbindung zwischen den Wurzeln und
einer wie auch immer gearteten Nährstoff
Verteilung ja schon im Hinterkopf aber
da muss man ja sehr genau hingucken wenn
man hier diese kleinen Bäumchen
entdecken will warum sind die eigentlich
so klein wenn die schon so viele Jahre
alt sind die Elternbäume die Drosseln
den Lichteinfall bis auf 3% des
Sonnenlichts runter also es ist
eigentlich ganz ganz dunkel für diese
kleinen Bäume und das ist der Sinn der
Sache man hat herausgefunden dass nur
Bäume die in den ersten Z bis 300 Jahren
sehr langsam wachsen uralt werden können
und deswegen werden die eben gebremst
die bilden ein ganz dichtes zähes Holz
wo Pilze auch später ganz schlecht drin
wachsen können das heißt wenn die mal
eine Verletzung haben heilen die das gut
aus wenn ein Sturm so ein Baum später
mal biegt dann ist er sehr elastisch
weil dieses Licht der Holz eben sehr
viel widerstandsfähiger ist ja und um
all das zu erzeugen bremsen die Eltern
die Elternbäume ihren Nachwuchs so
ähnlich wie bei uns Menschen auch wo man
den Kindern sagt mach mal langsam renn
mal nicht so schnell über die Straße
pass mal ein bisschen auf nur dieses
pass mal ein bisschen auf dauert halt
ein paar Jahrhunderte nun ist das was
wir hier in einem Wald sehen und es gibt
ja ganz viele die gerne in den Wald
gehen spazieren gehen der
Sonntagnachmittag Spaziergang ist eine
bekannte Tradition in Deutschland man
geht aber im Grunde genommen über solche
äh geheimnisvollen Dinge hinweg man
sieht die erstmal nicht das ist ja das
Spannende was sie uns in ihrem Buch auch
erzählen dass das ganz ganz viele Dinge
gibt die man auf dem aus dem ersten
Blick nicht feststellt aber wie haben
sie das denn festgestellt wie sind Sie
denn da drauf gekommen jetzt ganz viele
Details dieses Lebens der Bäume zu
erkennen eigentlich eine ganz
merkwürdige Sache und
zwar als Förster sieht man Bäume ja nur
in Form von Brettern oder in Form von
Papierholz oder in Form von Spar
schattenholz also das heißt ich muss
innerhalb von Bruchteilen von Sekunden
Bäume nach Qualitätsstufen einteilen
weil ich im normalen fsterleben Bäume
anzeichne die dann gefällt werden sollen
und wenn man das mehrere hundert Mal am
Tag macht und über viele Jahre hinweg
dann sieht man Bäume nicht mehr als Baum
und
interessanterweise das ist ein reiner
Wirtschaftsfaktor ist ein reiner
Wirtschaftsfaktor also Bäume sind Holz
deswegen reden wir übrigens firstster in
der Fachsprache auch von Nadelholz und
Laubholz und nicht von Laubbäumen und
Nadelbäumen und wir haben hier diesen
Jahrtausende alten Buchenwald gerettet
indem wir ihn zu einem Ruheforst also zu
einem Bestattungswald gemacht haben so
und da sind die Leute rausgekommen und
konnten sich einen Baum als lebenden
Grabstein kaufen um sich dort später
beisetzen zu lassen und die Leute haben
gesagt ach der ist aber so schön krumm
der Baum das ist so wie das wie das
richtige Leben so wie bei mir auch und
ich habe gedacht nein das ist kein
schöner Baum der ist do total krumm das
ist do Schrott oder die Äste waren so
tief angesetzt und iresagt ach das ist
aber so schön beschirmend so behüten das
finde ich schön ich daagt nein das ist
qualitätstufe c also das ist ganz
schlecht das geht überhaupt nicht äh
natürlich ist es Quatsch und es ist ja
fast peinlich dass man als Förster Bäume
nicht mehr vernünftig sehen kann aber
ich habe wirklich mit diesen Leuten den
Wald wieder mit normalen Augen sehen
gelernt und dann dann bin ich über Dinge
gestolpert die mir vorher völlig
entgangen sind das ist aber jetzt nicht
nur ihre eigene Beobachtung sondern sie
haben ja festgestellt es gibt ganz viel
Forschung zu bestimmten Dingen bei den
Bäumen die sogar bekannt ist
ähm was sind die Dinge die in der
Wissenschaft seit langem bekannt sind
auf die sie quasi noch mal Hinweisen
jetzt in ihrem Buch also das
verblüffenste vielleicht dass Bäume
miteinander sprechen das weiß man seit
den 70er Jahren dass Bäume sich z.B
vorwarnen wenn sie von Schädlingen
befallen werden also wenn beispielsweise
ein Borkenkäfer sich in den Baum einburt
dann tut dem das weh da laufen wirklich
auch elektrische Signale in dem Baum der
lagert Abwehrstoffe dann ein weil er den
dieses vie ich wieder loswerden will und
der denkt eben nicht nur an sich sondern
der über ein Gas was er ausstößt seine
Nachbarn in der Umgebung vor und die
können alle vorsorglich schon
Abwehrstoffe einlagern und sind
gewappnet und diese Forschung die ist
seit ja also seit mindestens 40 Jahren
bekannt aber hat sich eben nicht so im
Bewusstsein durchgesetzt weil diese
Forschungsergebnisse halt sehr sehr
trocken präsentiert werden jetzt gibt es
so einen Begriff der Vermenschlichung
das ist so ein Begriff der immer dann
eingesetzt wird wenn man sagt nun lass
doch mal die Natur die ist eben anders
als wir wir wollen das immer nur a aus
dem menschlichen Auge sehen wie gehen
sie denn mit so einem Vorwurf um dass
wir jetzt sagen na ja das ist ja ein
Baum und es ist ein Lebewesen und der
ist so ähnlich wie wir der agiert so
ähnlich und dann sagen andere nee nee
das ist vor allen Dingen erstmal Holz
und das hat mit dem Menschen eigentlich
gar nichts zu tun also wir Menschen
funktionieren ja zu 80 90% mindestens
über Emotionen das heißt wenn wir die
Emotionen aus der Sprache rauslassen
dann endmenschlichen wir Sprache das
heißt wir verstehen sie nicht mehr und
das ist genau das was forschungsbericht
machen da sind keine Emotionen drin und
deswegen liest sie keiner und deswegen
versteht die auch keiner zumindest kein
Nichtfachmann oder Frau und das ist
genau das was ich wieder zurückbringe
ich bringe in diese Sprachen Emotionen
rein und wenn wir z.B sagen diese
mutterbuche stillt ihren Nachwuchs dann
weiß sofort jeder was gemeint ist wenn
ich jetzt irgendwelche biochemischen und
biophysikalischen Prozesse hier anführe
aufgedröselt bis in den atomaren Bereich
dann g gnt jeder und sagt will ich gar
nicht wissen und das berührt mich auch
nicht und das ist halt schade das ist
genau der Punkt den ich eben gerne
ändern
würde dann reden wir jetzt mal über die
Gefühle der Bäume und vermenschlichen es
nicht sondern akzeptieren einmal dass es
bei den Bäumen auch Gefühle gibt und
dass die auch mit Gefühlen umgehen und
was die Folgen von solchen Gefühlen sind
und Beispiele haben wir ja hier genug
ja ja die Menschen sind jetzt gerade
auch im Herbst begeistert von den Farben
die wir hier sehen aber in jedem Blatt
sind verschiedene Farben zu sehen genau
also man kann sich einfach mal
irgendeins rausgreifen so wie hier das
hier und da sieht man das dass wir hier
braun haben gelb grün das hängt damit
zusammen dass der Baum versucht hat dass
die Reservestoffe aus das Chlorophyll
rauszuziehen und das ist im hier nicht
ganz gelungen weil hier kleine Piraten
sitzen nämlich Pilz und Bakterien die
möchten das für sich behalten und
einfach noch auch wenn das Blatt schon
runtergefallen ist ein zwei Wochen davon
Zhen aber das schadet dem Baum
nicht
besonders faszinierend jetzt im
Augenblick ist natürlich nicht nur die
Farbe der Blätter sondern auch wie sie
sehr unterschiedlich
Abfallen der eine Baum ist schon mehr
oder weniger kahl der andere hat noch
sehr viel Laub ist das zufällig oder
gibt es da ein System hinter da gibt's
schon ein System dahinter oder was
eigentlich viel schöner ist da gibt's
Charaktere dahinter die Bäume die sind
ganz unterschiedlich wagemutig die
werfen ihre Blätter ab damit sie dem
Schnee nicht so viel Widerstand bieten
dem Sturm nicht so viel Widerstand
bieten im Winter damit sie eben nicht
abbrechen und das kann man als Baum nur
machen wenn man wach ist aber wenn keine
Blätter mehr dran sind ist ein Baum im
Winterschlaf das heißt also er muss
vorher sehen dass er seine Reservestoffe
aus den Blättern holt und sie dann aktiv
abstößt nur wann ist es Winter das weiß
man als Baum nicht und da gibt es
vorsichtige die sagen also das hat immer
schon frühen Schnee Einbruch gegeben und
der Winter kommt dann doch ganz flott
dann werde ich meine Blätter nicht mehr
los das ist für gefährlich ich schmeiße
die jetzt schon mal runter und es gibt
aber auch andere so wie diesen hier der
hat noch so gelbgrüne Blätter also ist
sehr sehr spät dran der sich vielleicht
einfach gedacht hat hey goldenen Oktober
das haben wir do immer noch gehabt da
kann man doch noch zwei Wochen Zucker
tanken und sie wollen mir nicht
ernsthaft sagen dass die Bäume sich so
etwas überlegen also ob die sich das
überlegen also muss man mittlerweile
ganz vorsichtig sein Bäume haben
beispielsweise ein Gedächtnis das weiß
man Bäume können zählen also im früher
geht's ja umgekehrt zum Laubabfall die
Bäume treiben auch nur die Frage wann ne
wann gibt's keine Spätfröste mehr und
hat man festgestellt anhand von
Obstbäumen dass Bäume die Zahl der
warmen Tage über 20° zähen jetzt weiß
man sie können zählen und die nächste
das nächste was man weiß ist sie haben
ein Gedächtnis aber wo um Gottes willen
ist das denn im Baum untergebracht ich
meine sie sind groß sie sind
sie haben Platz aber man kann doch nicht
eine Festplatte finden wir sind ja alle
so durch Technologie geprägt inzwischen
dass wir immer nach Festplatten suchen
nach irgendwelchen Tastaturen suchen was
ist denn da beim Baum genau also wir
sind eben logischerweise auf uns selber
geprägt und wir müssen einen Kopf haben
und ein Gehirn ein zentrales
Nervensystem ob ein Baum sowas hat oder
ob der das dezentral
abspeichert das weiß man alles noch
nicht also das ist ja das Problem
vielleicht auch das schöne an
Grundlagenforschung eine Frage
beantwortet zehn neue Fragen gestellt
und so ist es hier auch also man weiß
dass Bäume sich viele Dinge merken
können man weiß auch dass sie eben
unterschiedliche Charaktere haben sowie
dieser hier der eben sehr riskant lebt
und einfach die Fotosynthese noch weit
in den November reinzieht das das machen
Bäume aber wo die das haben wo die auch
ihre Gefühle sozusagen registrieren das
wissen wir alles noch nicht aber wenn
sie sagen die Bäume haben Gefühle dann
müssten wir ja auch ganz anders mit
ihnen umgehen dann ist es ja so wie bei
einem Tier den wir ja Gott sei Dank
inzwischen wenn wir einigemaßen
zivilisatorisch äh klar denken und
aufgeklärt sind zugestehen es ist eine
Lebewesen um dass wir uns kümmern müssen
oder dass wir zumindest respektieren
müssen ist das beim Baum im Zweifel auch
so das wird beim Baum so kommen bei
Schweinen übrigens darf man auch heute
noch bis zum dritten Lebenstag ohne
Betäubung kastrieren W einfach sagt dann
haben die noch keine Gefühle das weiß
natürlich auch jeder Zuschauerin und
jeder Zuschauer das ist nicht so diese
Tiere haben selbstverständlich Gefühle
bei Bäumen weiß die Wissenschaft das
auch aber noch hält die Forst und
Holzindustrie diese Information zurück
oder registriert so vielleicht auch gar
nicht weil man dann mit diesen Bäumen
anders umgehen müsste und ich glaube das
Bewusstsein kommt langsam und ich würde
eine Wette eingehen wenn wir uns in 20
Jahren noch mal treffen dann stehen wir
bei den Bäumen da wo wir heute mit der
Massentierhaltung stehen in Diskussion
wir diskutieren bei Tieren inzwischen
die Frage ob das nicht mehr ist als ein
Sachgegenstand wenn etwas passiert mit
einem Tier wird das vom Gesetz her immer
noch als Sachgegenstand gesehen und
nicht als
Lebewesen könnte es sein dass wir die
nächste Stufe dann damit erreichen dass
wir auch dem Baum als Lebewesen
zugestehen ja er hat Gefühle er hat
ein Gedächtnis wie sie sagen und wir
müssen anders mit ihm umgehen ja und in
der Schweiz ist das schon so da stehen
Pflanzen schon in der Verfassung drin
und was häufig verwechselt wird wenn wir
Bäumen Gefühle zugestehen was heißt
zugestehen die haben die ja dann heißt
das ja nicht dass man die nicht mehr
nutzen darf sondern heißt das lediglich
dass man die verantwortungsvoller nutzen
sollte das heißt dort wo es möglich ist
denen mehr Freiheiten Z gestehen sie
einfach artgerecht wachsen zu lassen
ihren Sozialverband ausleben zu lassen
und sich zweimal zu überlegen brauchen
wir dieses Holz tatsächlich und wenn wir
die Frage mit Ja beantworten dann können
wir selbstverständlich auch Holz mit
gutem Gewissen nutzen wenn das so ist so
ähnlich wie heute Tiere eben aus
artgerechte
Haltung was ist denn der Grund dafür
dass wir das im Augenblick noch nicht
akzeptieren dass wir das äh nicht nur
als nicht aufgeklärter Spaziergänger
sondern dann vor allen Dingen auch von
politischer und gesellschaftlicher Seite
als Holz ansehen und nicht als Lebewesen
das lässt sich damit viel einfacher
hantieren also wenn sie tatsächlich
jedes Mal wenn Sie eine Motorsäge
ansetzen oder die Kreissäge um Bretter
zu produzieren drüber nachdenken dass
sie dort ein Lebewesen was eine reiche
Gefühlspalette hat zerlegen dann fällt
das deutlich schwerer und dann fällt
auch der Konsum deutlich schwerer was
ich persönlich schön finde wir
konsumieren sowieso zu viel an solchen
Produkten
wenn wir damit verantwortungsvoller
umgehen ist das umsatzschädlich gar
keine Frage und wir sind momentan leider
obwohl sich das seit Jahrzehnten anders
diskutiert ist ja immer noch in diesem
Wachstumswahn und dem würden Bäume mit
Gefühlen ein kräftigen Riegel
vorschieben für wie sensibel halten Sie
denn die Bevölkerung die ja in
bestimmten Bereichen reagiert also man
möchte heute bilebensmittel die will man
gerne beim Discounter kaufen weil da
sind zu günstiger und wir wissen
manchmal kommen sie aus Ägypten ist
eigentlich zumindest ökologisch Blödsinn
aber wie sensibel ist die Bevölkerung
auf
solche Thesen oder nachgewiesenen Dinge
zu reagieren und zu sagen ja da müssen
wir dann auch anders mit Wäldern mit
Bäumen umgehen überraschenderweise sehr
sensibel das hätte ich gar nicht gedacht
ehrlich gesagt weil wir ja seit
Jahrzehnten mit Holz relativ unsensibel
umgehen ne also alle finden waldchön
aber der einzelne Baum und was da so ist
das will man vielleicht auch gar nicht
wissen hätte ich gedacht aber das stimmt
nicht also die das Feedback was ich
bekomme aus der Bevölkerung das ist dass
die Leute sagen wow das sind so
wundervolle Wesen schön dass wir endlich
etwas darüber erfahren und nur dann kann
ja auch der einzelne entscheiden nutze
ich das oder lass ich den Baum lieber im
Wald stehen solange das einfach nur ein
Rohstoff ist und die ganzen Emotionen
außen vorbleiben hat man ja gar keine
echte Wahl ne dann ist es nämlich fast
egal ob man etwas dort tut oder nicht
und in dem Augenblick wo das fühlende
Wesen sind die einfach eine ganz tolle
Lebensgeschichte auch haben da kann man
wirklich entscheiden gönne ich das
diesem oder brauche ich selber z.B ein
warmen Ofen weil ich sonst friere ne und
dann kann man wirklich eine vernünftige
Entscheidung treffen wie haben sie das
erlebt wir hatten einen Zeitpunkt in den
70er Jahren da hat ein großes deutsches
Nachrichtenmagazin an Titel gemacht der
hieß der Wald stirbt das war die größte
Emotionen in Deutschland die man glaube
ich jemals dem Wald und den gegenüber
hatte dass die Bevölkerung der Meinung
war so jetzt stirbt unser Wald wir haben
ja eine starke Beziehung zum Wald wir
haben viele Märchen die im Wald spielen
also durchaus eine Beziehung zum Wald
und plötzlich war da die Angst uns
sterben die Wälder Weg das ist nachher
so ein bisschen wieder
ja zurückgenommen worden weil man gesagt
hat so schlimm ist es eigentlich gar
nicht es gibt den Wald Zustandsbericht
jedes Jahr der sagt da so dramatisch ist
das nicht wir haben viel erreicht was
ist denn seit den 1 er Jahren aus ihrer
Sicht als Förster mit dem Wald passiert
der Wald ist tatsächlich noch mehr zur
Plantage verkommen der ist zwar in
unserem Bewusstsein ökologisch
aufgewertet worden weil wir diese
Hochglanzbroschüren der staatlichen
Forstverwaltung für bareare Münze nehmen
in Klammern diese forßverwaltung
bewirtschaften aber große Teile des
Waldes selber haben also wirtschaftliche
Interessen und in unserer Fantasie oder
in unseren Gedanken ist der Wald jetzt
immer wertvoller geworden ökologisch ist
es alles zum Guten hingewendet und
tatsächlich äh findet draußen ein ganz
brutale industrieforstwirtschaft statt
mit Großmaschinen mit auch mit
gifteinsätzen
mit Nadelbaum Plantagen es wird nur
nicht so genannt und weil wir uns alle
doch so ein bisschen an das positive
Image des firststers anlehnen der uns
dort eben draußen erzählt es sei alles
in Ordnung deswegen wiegt sich ein
Großteil der Bevölkerung eben noch in
der Sicherheit dass das ein relativ
intaktes Ökosystem ist was es aber nicht
ist aber wenn wenn ich durch einen Wald
gehe und sehe da wird mit großen
Maschinen arbeitet und äh jeder sagt mir
der verantwortlich ist wir können doch
da nicht wieder mit Pferden durchgehen
was es ja durchaus gibt es gibt ja auch
wieder diese Transporte mit Pferden was
ist denn der Unterschied dazu hat das
einfach nur mit
wirtschaftlich ökonomisch sinnvollen
Alternativen zu tun oder hat das auch
Folgen für den Wald also übrigens kann
man mit Pferden arbeiten das machen wir
auch schon seit 20 Jahren nur mit
Waldarbeitern und Pferden ja das hat
massive Folgen für den Wald wenn sie mit
einer schweren Maschine über den
Waldboden fahren so ein waldboden ist
wie ein lockerer schwamm sie fahren
drüber und dieser Schwamm quetscht sich
bis in 2 m Tiefe zusammen geht im
Gegensatz zu einem echten Schwamm aber
nie wieder hoch tatsächlich nie wieder
also experten sagen vielleicht nach der
nächsten Eiszeit und dann nach der
nächsten Eiszeit würde ein
solcher Schwamm wieder funktionieren bis
dahin ist das zerstört bis dahin ist das
zerstört also für möglicherweise für
Jahr 10tausende und das
Wasserspeichervermögen nach so einer
maschinenüberfahrt geht um bis zu 95%
zurück das heißt die Wälder die den
winterniederschlag im Sommer brauchen
dringend brauchen die verdursten dann
und dann sagen alle so wie z. in diesem
trockenen Sommer auchch das ist der
Klimawandel und das ist die trockene
Witterung deswegen geht's im Wald so
schlecht nein es ist tatsächlich
überwiegend die Forstwirtschaft denn ein
gesunder Wald so wie dieser hier der
kann solche Klimaextreme oder
Wetterextreme sind es ja eigentlich die
kann der bequem abreiten also so ein
Wald wie dieser der kann z.B die
Temperatur im Sommer um bis zu 3°
absenken durch ein gemeinsames schwitzen
der Bäume die verdunzen also Wasser
genau wie bei uns auch die kühlen sich
damit herunter dadurch verdunstet der
Boden weniger Wasser und der Wald kommt
auch durch monatelange Trockenphasen
wenn man ihn in Ruhe lässt wenn jetzt
die Bäume untereinander sozusagen in
irgendeiner Form verbunden sind wie sie
das beschrieben haben eine Art von
Kommunikation haben heißt das auch sie
überlegen sich wie sie auf bestimmte
Situationen reagieren und der eine gibt
dann diese Information weiter
gibt es so etwas wie eine Solidarität
der Bäume die gibt es also n ganz
rührend sogar also Bäume vernetzen sich
über die Wurzeln und wenn einer krank
ist dann wird er von den anderen wieder
aufgepeppelt weil Bäume ein Interesse
daran haben die Gemeinschaft zu erhalten
weil nur als Gemeinschaft kann man z.B
diese kühlenden Effekte erzielen das
heißt ein einzelner Baum in der Stadt
oder im Park der ist eigentlich
schutzlos aber die Gemeinschaft die
umsorgt sich gegenseitig die pflegt sich
gegenseitig die warnt sich gegenseitigor
und eben nicht nur über Duftstoffe
sondern auch über die Wurzeln über
elektrische Signale also wirklich wie
das Internet Pilze unterstützen dabei
ganz massiv also auf so ein
teelöffelchen Walderde gehen mehrere
Kilometer Pilzfäden das ist alles
durchwoben s dass die Wissenschaft von
einem woodwide Web also von dem Internet
des Waldes spricht und ja es ist ein ein
sehr sehr solidarisches System und wenn
der Mensch dort eben eingreift durch
absägen von Bäumen ne man hört das ja
häufig der Wald muss verjüngt werden wir
müssen dort Wirtschaften um ihn fit zu
halten
na ja also wenn man es mal ganz hässlich
ausdrückt das ist so ähnlich als wenn
sie in eine Familie gehen und sagen wir
Muren jetzt mal die Eltern ab dann
geht's den Kindern besser da haben die
mehr Platz in der Wohnung ne nürich auch
Quatsch und genauso geht's den kleinen
Bäumen auch wenn Sie einen Mutterbaum
absägen die wachsen dann zwar schnell
weil die auf Licht reflexartig mit
Wachstum reagieren aber die verausgaben
sich dabei also den geht's deutlich
schlechter diese Solidarität der Bäume
untereinander dieses helfen in Notlagen
sie haben gerade beschrieben das kann
ganz schnell im Sommer sein wenn zu
wenig Wasser da ist also dass äh äh eine
Solidarität unter den Bäumen besteht das
möchte ich mir gerne mal von ihnen
zeigen lassen
ja was hier so aussieht wie bemooste
Steine das sind in Wirklichkeit Reste
von einem uralten Baumstumpf der so hier
so sie stehen also quasi mittend drin
das hinten das gehört noch mit dazu also
ein riesiger eine riesige Buch hat hier
gestanden vor 4 500 Jahren und das ist
das was davon übrig ist äh alte Reste
und das ist noch lebendiges Holz das hab
man mit Studenten mal so ganz vorsichtig
ein bisschen die Rinde runtergenommen
und gesehen ah hat da ist sogar noch
grün drunter und der lebt das heißt der
verbraucht Zucker der lebt genau wie wie
wir beide auch die Frage ist ohne ein
grünes Blatt wie geht das und das geht
tatsächlich nur weil die Nachbarbäume
den über wurzelverwachsung miternähren
mit Zuckerlösung versorgen seit 4 bis
500 Jahren diesen alten für den Wald
scheinbar wertlosen stumpf und das finde
ich in ungeheuen Ausdruck ungeheuen
sympathischen Ausdruck dafür wie
solidarisch Bäume untereinander sind es
ist eben dann nicht so dass gesagt wird
äh na ja gut der ist umgefallen dann ist
er tot und dann haben wir Ruhe dafür
sind wir dann stärker sondern es es ganz
offenbar so dass da jemand mitgezogen
wird was was steckt denn dahinter
möglicherweise also das sind jetzt
Spekulationen also was sicher ist das
ist dass Bäume ihre Gemeinschaft
erhalten wollen weil sie nur
zusammenstark sind zusammen ein eigenes
Klima erzeugen können in dem sich
wohlfühlen ne mit viel Schatten mit viel
Feuchtigkeit
aber auch es kann ja auch mal umgekehrt
sein dass es einem anderen Baum schlecht
geht der jetzt abgegeben hat und der
bekommt dann eben auch mal was zurück
das heißt das in videoum lebt dadurch
länger übrigens genau wie bei der
menschlichen Gesellschaft auch ne der
Einzelne ist nichts ne wenn man einen
von uns beiden alleine in die Sahara
setzen würde wä es wahrscheinlich sehr
schlecht als große Gruppe hier in der
sozialen Gemeinschaft haben wir alle
sehr gute Überlebenschancen und so ist
das bei Bäumen auch also die
unterstützen sich wirklich auf gedei und
Verderb und es ist eben nicht so wie uns
das häufig suggeriert wird ah die Bäume
die sten alle zu eng da müssen mal
welche raussägen damit die mal
ordentlich Platz haben nein Bäume sind
keine Egoisten
m das dürfen sie ja auch eigentlich gar
nicht sein denn wenn wir uns mal
angucken die Herbststürme als Beispiel
oder sehr starke Frostperioden heißt
doch man muss zusammenhalten man muss
sozusagen diesen Widrigkeiten gegenüber
stehen und das kann man eigentlich nur
wenn man sehr solidarisch ist genau also
beim Sturm sieht man das übrigens sehr
schön die erste Welle kommt der erste
erste große Wind dann biegen sich alle
Bäume gleich aber weil die alle
unterschiedlich konstruiert sind
schwingen die auch unterschiedlich stark
dann hin und her und Bremsen sich
dadurch in den Kronen wieder ab sieht
man also ganz ganz deutlich in solchen
intakten Wäldern während ein einzelner
Baum der biegt sich stark und dann kommt
die nächste Böhe und dann fällt er eben
um ne also es ist für Bäume ist es
wichtig aber es mag auch noch andere
Dinge geben es ist gar nicht gesichert
wo speichern Bäume ihr Wissen also man
weiß Bäume können sich Dinge merken z.B
über Jahrzehnte an Trockenheiten
erinnern weil die dann anschließend mit
Wasser anders umgehen wo speichern die
dieses diese Erinnerung diese
schmerzhaften Erinnerung ne wenn ein
Baum austrocknet dann gibt es Risse im
Holz das tut weh wo speichert er das
speichert er das in den Wurzeln ist das
hier ist das eigentlich noch ein Baum
der lebt ja noch ne also man weiß dass
in den Wurzelspitzen gehirnähnliche
Prozesse ablaufen also auch elektrisch
mit Entscheidungen innerhalb von
Sekunden z.B wenn es da darum geht in
welche Richtung wachsen wir als Wurzeln
wo welche wo gibt's Giftstoffe die man
vermeiden sollte und so weiter das steht
aber alles erst am Anfang also
möglicherweise hat dieser alte baumgreis
tatsächlich auch noch eine Bedeutung für
die
Gemeinschaft alle Dinge die sie jetzt
erwähnt haben ob das jetzt die
Kommunikation ist diese
Solidarität sind ja Dinge die man
durchaus erforscht hat das ist ja
durchaus bekannt das soll die
Begeisterung über ihr Buch nicht iieren
aber es sind ganz viele Dinge die
bekannt sind auch wissenschaftlich
nachgewiesen sind warum sind die nicht
so präsent wir wissen ganz viel über das
Tierreich über die Technologie sowieso
warum ist das beim Wald bei den Bäumen
nicht so das sind Informationen die
entweder aktiv oder aus Unwissenheit
zurückgehalten werden das heißt wenn sie
mit firststern sprechen und die Sägen
Bäume ab dann möchten die das gerne als
umweltwohltat verkaufen was es natürlich
definitiv nicht ist da wird ein Baum
geschlachtet genau wie ein Tier auch und
genau wie ein Tier was anschließend zu
Nahrungsmittel verarbeitet wird auch
noch einem vernünftigen Zweck dienen
kann genauso kann das Holz auch aber es
ist nicht grundsätzlich etwas Gutes für
den Wald und wenn man so anfängt über
Bäume nachzudenken auf dem Stand der
aktuellen Forschung dann muss man sagen
dann tut es einem wirklich um jeden
baumleid der abgesägt wird und das
sollte es auch finde ich ne das heißt
nicht dass man ihn dann nicht nutzen
kann aber eben mit einem ganz anderen
Bewusstsein und
logischerweise ich meine ich bin selber
Förster ich möchte auch Holz verkaufen
man vergrault ja seine eigene Kundschaft
mit solchen
Botschaften wir wollen noch mal auf
dieses Familienleben so ein bisschen
schauen es gibt ja eine ganz starke
Familienbeziehung untereinander bei den
Bäumen und es gibt dann auch ja etwas
überraschende Beziehungen zwischen etwa
den Müttern und den Kindern bei Bäumen
ja also wir haben uns das vorhin ja
schon mal angeschaut wie Mütter buchen
Mütter ihre Kinder sen und haben wir so
ein paar also ist eine ein uralter
Mutterbaum wie alt ist der ungefähr
geschätzt Z bis 400 Jahre also 200 Jahre
dieser Austrieb aber auch der ist aus
einem alten stumpf ausgetrieben deswegen
ist der unteren Bereich etwas knollig
und der und hier steht jetzt sein Kind
und dieses Kind ist durch Licht Fall
durch Licht Drosselung also durch
Schattenwurf so stark gebremst worden
Wachstum dass z.B ein so ein kleines
Äschen wie dieses hier schon knapp 30
Jahre lang wächst das heißt also dieses
Stückchen hier ist seit 30 Jahren
gewachsen der ganze Baum mindestens seit
100 also ist eine hundertjährige Buche
die wartet möglicherweise noch mal 200
Jahre bis die mutterbuche irgendwann mal
stirbt und diese kleine Buche hier groß
werden darf und solange wird die über
wurzelverwachsungen mit Zuckerlösung
ernährt also
gestellt wenn man solche Zeitdimensionen
sieht äh das ist faszinierend auf der
einen Seite auf der anderen Seite
erschreckend weil das reduziert
sozusagen unser Menschenalter im
Vergleich zu den Bäumen
ist das eine Faszination die sie auch
als Förster spüren ja also dieser diese
einfach diese Langfristigkeit also WN
man weiß eine baumjugend dauert Z bis
300 Jahre und dann kann ein Baum erst
alt werden dieses dieses austarierte in
diesem Ökosystem dieses soziale dieses
fürsorgliche und das eben in dieser
extremen Langsamkeit das finde ich total
entspannend ja sie finden es ja
wahrscheinlich nicht nur entspannend
sondern wahrscheinlich kommen ja auch
viele Menschen in den Wald um das
sozusagen mitzuerleben weil man sagt
zwar nicht unbedingt ich weiß wie alt
dieser Baum ist aber dass der älter ist
als ein Mensch ist das weiß jeder äh ist
das eine der Faszinationen die die
Menschen in die Wälder bringt also das
mag die eine Sache sein das andere ist
tatsächlich diese Entschleunigung ist ja
auch schon fast ein abgenutzter Begriff
der wird h aber sowas von deutlich in
diesem Wald dass eben diese ganzen
alltäglichen Dinge keine Rolle spielen
und wir für diese Bäume sowas wie ja
vielleicht fliegen sind die hier so
durchsirren die man gar nicht richtig
den Flügelschlag z.B nicht richtig sieht
und die im nächsten Augenblick schon
wieder weg sind so werden wir
möglicherweise von den Bäumen
wahrgenommen äh und das das erzeugt
einfach eine Beruhigung diese große Ruhe
auch vor allem dieses intakte Ökosystem
die dieser spezielle Wald hier auch
darstellt das gibt eine eine ganz tiefe
Form von Frieden gehen wir noch ein
Stück weiter
runter ja viele Menschen wollen nicht
nur im bald spazieren gehen sondern sich
dort auch bestatten lassen und das geht
hier auch was sind die Gründe für
Menschen zu sagen ich möchte im Wald
begraben
werden wer zu Lebzeiten gern in der
Natur unterwegs war gerne im Wald war
für den ist das die natürlichste
Grabstätte die man sich denken kann und
die ist ja auch besonders schön wenn man
sich so eine alte 180 bis 200jährige
bucheer als lebenden Grabstein kauft und
sich dort zu Füßen in Form einer ne
beisetzen lässt und der Baum wurzelt
dann in die sich auflösende ohne ein die
Asche geht in den Kreislauf der Natur
zurück das ist für viele ganz
tröstlicher Gedanke
das werden immer mehr Menschen wie kommt
das ja also es gibt nicht mehr die
Familienstrukturen die es früher gab das
heißt dass die Generationen
hintereinander am selben Ort wohnen und
auch die Gräber pflegen und dann müssen
Gärtnereien beauftragt werden und ja es
ist eigentlich nur noch lästig das muss
man schon sagen viele viele
grabpflegeaktionen und hier ist das
alles nicht erforderlich hier kann man
dann in den Wald gehen wenn einem danach
ist hier kommen auch interessanterweise
viele Familiie mit Kindern wieder raus
es ist ja kein langweiliger
Friedhofsbesuch sondern man geht in den
Wald man macht einen Sonntagsausflug
geht hinterher Kaffee trinken genauso
wie zu Lebzeiten eben mit Oma und Opa
auch und das ist etwas das spricht eben
sehr viele Menschen an und das nimmt
immer mehr zu das wären jetzt auch
organisatorische Gründe hat der Bezug
zur Natur sich auch verändert ist der
Bezug gerade zum Wald aufgrund der des
Alters des Waldes und der
Unmittelbarkeit des Waldes und der Bäume
stärker geworden ja also speziell bei
unserem Wald kommt eben dazu dass es ein
Naturschutzprojekt ist wo die Leute
sagen ich kann mit meinem Tod auch noch
was positives verbinden nämlich indem
ich naturschütze indem ich diesen alten
Baum und nicht nur den Baum sondern den
gesamten Alten Wald hier in himümels
Schütze und ja das ist einfach ein
schöner Gedanke dass das Grab eben nicht
nur einfach ja auch nach 20 30 Jahren
wieder abläuft sondern auch so ein Teil
dieser ewigen Kreisläufe hier in diesem
uralten Buchenwald
das heißt aber auch es gibt eine gewisse
Magie des Waldes nicht nur für deutsche
sondern auch für eigentlich alle
Menschen das liegt an der Zeitstruktur
das liegt aber auch irgendwo an dieser
Unmittelbarkeit zur
Natur das ist ja etwas was sie auch in
den Beruf des Försters geführt hat sonst
würden sie das ja nicht gemacht haben ja
klar das ist schon eine Naturliebe die
gar nicht näher spezifiziert ist und
diese Sehnsucht ich glaube die nimmt
analog zum Grad der Umweltzerstörung
insgesamt zu und es ist eben schön dass
es noch solche positiven Inseln gibt die
sich zu erhalten lohnt und wo man diese
ganzen Dinge eben auch beobachten kann
und das ist das was mich auch jeden Tag
wirklich zufrieden macht sie haben
erzählt von der Kommunikation der Bäume
untereinander von der Solidarität der
Bäume untereinander und auch von dem
Familienleben das sind zumindest für den
Lein sehr überraschende Erkenntnisse was
steht uns denn da noch bevor bei einigen
Punkten haben sie ja gesagt ja da weiß
man noch nicht ganz genau ist das so ein
bisschen noch Grundlagenforschung was
wir da erleben das ist fast reine
Grundlagenforschung und da steht uns mit
Sicherheit noch ganz viele spannende
Entdeckungen bevor also ich denke
beispielsweise daran dass wir in Bezug
auf baumkommunikation immer nur
Abwehrverhalten testen können also wenn
Käfer sich einbohrt wenn das und das
passiert aber was wo tauschen sich Bäume
aus wenn es ihnen gut geht ne jetzt Z in
diesem Wald wo alles in Ordnung ist was
passiert da zwischen den Bäumen also
mein Traum wäre so eine Art Wörterbuch
das kann ja ein Computer sein der Düfte
entschlüsseln kann und der mir dann
anzeigt was hier so gerade gesprochen
wird aber vielleicht erlebe ich das noch
wer weiß das heißt aber auch wir müssen
in Zukunft eigentlich schon jetzt mit
den Erkenntnissen die wir haben von dem
sie berichtet haben eigentlich mit den
Bäumen und den Wäldern anders umgehen
genau ich finde um noch mal auf das
Eingangsbild zurückzukommen dass wir
bäum wir wirklich sehen sollten wie
Elefanten dass sie einfach aus sich
heraus eine Naturschönheit sind und wenn
uns das nicht gelingen sollte dann
sollten wir wenigstens an uns selber
denken denn wirklich nur intakte Wälder
die wir in Deutschland wirklich kaum
noch haben sind in der Lage dem
Klimawandel standzalten den ganzen
Umweltveränderungen ne nur diese intakte
Solidargemeinschaft kann auf diese
kommenden Anforderungen und Aufgaben die
wir dem Wald Stellen reagieren können
wir als Menschen uns ein bisschen von
den Bäumen abgucken mit Sicherheit also
in punkto solidarität muss man sagen
sind Bäume wirklich innerhalb einer Art
uneingeschränkt solidarisch das heißt
sie teilen Sie denken nicht an sich
sondern denken an die Gemeinschaft das
ist eine und das zweite ist halt diese
unendliche Langsamkeit die so ein
bisschen auch die Hektik unserer Zeit
vielleicht abdämpfen kann und so ein
ganz klein bisschen mehr Geduld und Ruhe
vermitteln kann also das ist das was
zumindest ich persönlich da rausziehe
und nicht nur der setzt sich durch mit
dem Ellbogen ganz herzlichen Dank für
das Sprecher viel Spaß
[Musik]
[Applaus]
gemacht